parenting can be hard and not just for
busy moms but also dads and we want to
welcome one of the co-hosts of the Dad
cast podcast JP Pierce welcome to the
show thank you for having me I love what
you have built in the last two years you
uh you were someone who like me worked
in radio yep still do doing the thing
but then you decided you know what I
want to kind of become my own brand and
do my own thing and this was all built
out of the pandemic tell us a little bit
about your podcast correct well you know
podcasts are a pretty big deal these
days and two years ago they they
certainly were as well and my co-host
Nick Martin and myself we're both
dealing with some personal issues and we
decided to blow off some steam let's
come up with the podcast where we can
talk on our problems and and it has
blown up into a huge podcast top one and
a half percent in the world and we talk
with other celebrity dads about being
dads in the path and the adventure and
all the good things that come along with
it there's so much relatable content on
your podcast and if you're comfortable
telling us what were like the tough
things that you guys were going through
at the time that that created all of
them yes well nick uh had a baby and it
was right in the middle of the pandemic
so he was not allowed to be inside the
hospital to see and bond with his brand
new baby boy we're talking six weeks to
almost six months and on top of that his
child was in the NICU for a good six
weeks after birth with some serious
issues and on my end my uh beautiful
lady
she uh was dealing with breast cancer
and I had to get a double vasectomy
during all this time but I'm happy to
report we're all good now and she's
actually here yes she is I love seeing
it now your podcast you have a lot of
celebrities on there I mean pretty much
every episode and uh so who are some of
your favorite celebrities that you've
interviewed oh man we've had our local
boy here Randy Couture UFC champ movie
star uh recently Sean Patrick Flannery
from Boondock Saints oh man Daniel what
Society
Jordan former former NBA legend from the
Lakers Champion he lives here in Vegas
and do you have a pretty cool guest
coming up on the podcast that you're
releasing on Thursday yeah coming up
this Thursday it's a dual episode with
Barry Corbin who is the star in
Yellowstone the TV show I love that show
and Sean Ferris they both did a movie
called The Bay house and they appeared
and we talked dad alive with them it's
great so people want to download the
podcast tell us where where do they find
it Well they can find it anywhere they
get their podcasts but we would like to
encourage you to go to the YouTube
channel dadcast podcast where you can
actually get a visual of everything
that's going on with the podcast but you
know it doesn't matter if you're in your
car you're driving or wherever anywhere
you get your podcast it is available
anywhere you can get it and it's great
stuff you'll have to check it out thank
you so much for joining us thank you
coming up we're going to